hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to totally accurate
battle simulator now I just had to play
more of this because it's a fascinating
game and I'm readily discovering that
I'm a military genius and I should be
employed by the army if that's how
that's even done it's not anyway so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna I'm gonna
shield up in a strategically no way I'm
gonna fast forward and then reveal my
amazing plan alright so this is my
amazing battle plan in it I took so long
the music's even stopped but this is
gonna be good you guys are gonna wait
until it's good and then you're gonna
see how good it is so we got the shields
only three of them because I don't think
we need and we got spearmint over here
we got farmers over here because the
farmers are the best bet I guess we got
Muscat Minh way in the back and are
probably gonna kill all my friends and I
didn't even think about that one I
should probably rethink that idea but
I'm gonna have people coming in from way
down town who will hopefully clear these
guys out and that's gonna be better so
I've got some money left over but I
think there's gonna get it ha Bisky
get him get him kill him dad murder him
murder everybody kill him kill them all
kill them all go so the main problem is
those cannons seem to be blasting them
away when they're all dense like this so
oh that's good oh [ __ ] see they're all
dense like that well get um stab em in
da booty there we go
oh hello hi Brad how you doing okay so
there oh god what happened to everybody
it's just the cannons they've had oh and
the archers to your knit gosh darn it
there's Durney this didn't work at all
this sucks I'm gonna get through this
BRB we're gonna we're gonna bum-rush um
with chariots with three chariots and
then from way down town a bunch of
farmers okay ready
chariots go wow why did that throw the
cannon here got thrown on that one okay
well that one failed but it knocked over
that cannon so that's good go for the
cannon go for the kill go for the throat
yeah oh oh oh he got obliterated
oh gosh okay let me try that again cuz
we need two chariots on the outskirts
and then a lot of farmers way up north
here yeah just a slew of farmers this
will do it this is gonna do it get him
ahhh Wow okay well one down yeah get
that yeah there we go okay so I'm
falling this chariot in no joke that's
our team no you idiot you dang fool you
aah all right but the chariot strategy
is gonna work I guarantee it so I'm
gonna give the chariots not a lot of
room to have to go they don't have to go
very far and hopefully is gonna work out
for the best farmers go farmers go yes
no don't hit each other
okay the chariots are still alive
they're still doing good okay no god
damn it
both chariots and one what a sack of
[ __ ] oh man okay all right so we're
gonna have archers over here and then
farmers there we go this is gonna be the
one you watch this go get em our cheese
go get him go get him
I doesn't work at all
you sack of [ __ ] I'm gonna get you I'm
coming
you miss me [ __ ] you can't hear will
you come I've betrayed my family and
friends I am the dead
oh they're locked in an epic struggle
here Wow yeah I do it yeah I don't know
how but it worked okay so what I'm gonna
have here we're gonna have a chariot
rush cuz I have no damn idea what
there's gonna be do it oh the chariot
rush Holies ahh
buddy buddy buddy oh ok well Jesus I did
not know that it was gonna be yeah
we had fewer chariots but ours are
superior because I can only assume that
there's killed each other
great ok nothing but watches this is
gonna work probably maybe farmers get in
the way of the watches what's up what's
up bubs ah holy crap hahahaha
that is so cool oh man hmm alright well
this was a mistake
Wow Wow
that was embarrassing that was pathetic
and embarrassing and I love it we're
gonna do chariots because actually I
have a funny feeling that chariots are
gonna do pretty good here hands a
footman maybe some muskets
alright go for broke whoa oh you got
caught up a little bit there who that is
that didn't look so good
ah I go get him
Gil whoa okay you're doing it you're a
1-mile [ __ ]
oof okay so what we need we need her we
need two cannons like like two cannons
firing up the middle is what we really
need and then I bet we can employ the
musket strategy and then have one
chariot leading the charge here so
cannons and chariot is gonna be it go
buddy go whoa
right up the middle yes Oh devastation
he's an unstoppable beast look at him go
look at him go
holy [ __ ] look at him go Oh hot damn
this is my jam oh [ __ ] this guy is nuts
oh man get him buddy oh you can't stop
the horse he girl whoa the Sidewinder on
that wall No our cannons took him out
huh I will avenge my team that he can't
hit me I have the power
holy [ __ ] oh my god ring the face it's
just somebody's either dopey ass walk
anyway so that worked out pretty well
one chariot leading the charge seemed to
do a pretty good job and then the cannon
crews kind of kind of swept it not bad
not bad at all oops
BAM okay get him get him buddy get him
what is that in the back was that with
chickens what's he up to
are you [ __ ] out chickens the hell
is that the hell are you Oh God
what are you going on here
Oh God look a chicken bombs so they are
Oh God Oh
oh my god Oh Oh God how can you
withstand power of that magnitude oh my
god we gotta take it out we got to take
out chicken man like right off the bat
so what I'm gonna do I'm gonna put a
watch uh front and center I'm probably
like right back here okay then we're
gonna have musket men back here and then
farmers leading up good charge okay that
should do it
trust me this is gonna do watch that
chicken man yeah we got him you got some
chickens out but it's okay
always saw alive how is he still alive
that's impossible
he's unstoppable oh my god it's
unstoppable
where is he on my work here is done hey
gee Hanyu pinyin hey oh man well you
guys aren't gonna last much longer man
we got to get rid of this guy he's
unstoppable have cannoneers on the
outskirts catapults on the innards
maybe ballista ballista crews on the
oh that's expensive one ballista Oh
poachers poachers would be good poachers
might be able to take out the chickens
quickly that might be good that might
actually work I mean it probably won't
considering all my plans never seem to
work but let's give it a go
get him get him poachy fire or don't
whatever way you want to swing this you
guys want to get you know started oh god
he's cleaving through him Oh God they're
cleaving through him oh oh oh hey well
then BAM spin around get him get him on
the upswing Wow where are you going
ballista man you're going ballistic
I beat the pre-alpha yeah I don't know
how uh okay that's in the van so I can't
believe it I beat it I beat the game
that's awesome I did pretty good okay so
I'm gonna wait what's sandbox this is
where we can make anything literally
anything happen okay let's do one of
these I want to see oh oh oh yes okay so
chariots versus uh nothing but watches
we're gonna do chariot watch a showdown
it's gonna go good I bet is it even
gonna oh oh oh I broke it I broke it I
broke it I broke it I broke it
Oh God why did I decide to do that holy
[ __ ] oh my god holy crap is anybody
still alive oh oh one guy still live
back there good job blue good job okay
I'm gonna my computer probably won't
handle this either versus Muscat Minh
but less of them
here we go or it's not gonna work okay
yeah boy oh boy oh boy oh boy it's gone
oh please okay oh that that was one of
those not good ideas now about this a
line of farmers versus a line of musket
men who's gonna win first any minute now
there we go there's the onslaught there
we go that's that's murder
that's nice delicious murder oh oh oh oh
don't fire till you see the whites of
their eyes
yeah holy [ __ ] get him get him boys
get him boys get them dog pile on him oh
jeez oh Jesus scary ass farmers this man
is a massacre oh boy yeah carry his
corpse with you that way it just scares
the opponents even more yeah Luigi go
get you loo look at you it's come down
to this oh what a showdown oh there we
go
I was not surprisingly close for what it
was all right so anyway that is all for
totally accurate battle simulator that
was a lot of fun I had a ton of fun with
that I can't wait to see what actual
game is gonna come out of this I have no
idea but either way thank you all so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]
what no it's time for a falafel hyung
what is floor of a pong you talking
about